[Musique]
il y a encore 8 mois ce bout du crâne
orienta était surnommé la Suisse du
Dombas mais le charme de sviator Hills a
laissé la place à la désolation
détruite par les combats d'artillerie la
ville a ensuite été occupée jusqu'à ce
que les forces ukrainiennes repoussent
leur ennemi
comme dans la plupart des territoires
qui ont été occupés par les Russes ici
l'immense majorité de la population a
quitté la ville plus de 90% en
l'occurrence et pour ceux qui sont
restés les trois mois et demi
d'occupation mais aussi les intenses
combats ont laissé des traces
indélébiles Yeffet a toujours vécu ici
cette babouchka de 76 ans s'aventure à
nouveau dehors après des mois passés
terrés chez elle donne Unity
évoque les anciens occupants de la ville
sujet tabou le ton change et sa voix se
fait plus discrète
[Musique]
le prédécesseur de volodi MIRR le maire
de la ville a collaboré puis s'est enfui
avec les Russes battait en retraite les
Dils actuels est un membre des Forces de
Défense territoriales du crâne pour lui
la situation ne souffre aucune ambiguïté
au chocolat
a toujours été partagé entre kif et
Moscou après la reprise de la ville par
les forces ukrainiennes certains ici
refusent de nous parler
elle nous accueille avec un grand
sourire au milieu de ses cultures de
lavande
puis s'effondre au moment de décrire son
havre de paix envahi du jour au
lendemain
une colère et une émotion refoulée
depuis des mois bébé
emploie le mot orque des créatures
mythiques répugnantes et barbares une
insulte que certains
Ukrainiens utilisent pour désigner les
soldats russes mais elle nous confie que
nombre de ses voisins ne partagent pas
sa haine elle soupçonne même une grande
partie de ceux qui sont restés de
sympathiser avec Moscou anibou
le monastère ukrainien orthodoxe dont
parle l'UDA se trouve à quelques
centaines de mètres de l'autre côté de
la rivière de Nieppe
il opère sous le Patriarcat de Moscou et
depuis des années certains s'interrogent
sur sa loyauté
l'édifice a été frappé par un
bombardement en mars
les mois nous ont affirmé y avoir abrité
400 personnes dans le sous-sol mais on
refusait de nous donner d'autres
informations
[Musique]
ce site culturel a tiré jusqu'à 300 000
pèlerins et touristes par an une
industrie locale réduite à néant
Alexander revient à fiatoès pour la
première fois depuis le départ des
troupes russes
et découvre ce qu'il reste de son hôtel
4 étoiles
après avoir perdu son travail et sa
maison difficile de se projeter vers
l'avenir
[Musique]
une course contre la montre est
désormais lancée pour déblayer les
ruines et commencer à reconstruire avant
l'hiver
mais la profonde fracture entre ceux
dont le cœur balance d'un côté ou de
l'autre de la frontière ne guérira
peut-être jamais
[Musique]